not you but some people might think
strategically business-wise it may be a
good idea to distance myself from my
parents I was told that we need to focus
on your brand Savannah but Savannah
wasn't having it those are my parents so
I'm not just gonna give up when the
going gets tough what we will not do is
we will not break the Chrisley Knows
Best star faces a whole new reality we
thank you for your continued prayers and
your support parents Todd and Julie
Behind Bars serving a combined 19-year
prison sentence my dad and I we have
such a special bond all of my siblings
know it my dad is my best friend I love
my children more than I've ever loved
anything in life we all share the same
common Bond of faith and we're going to
always be there for each other as she
explains to Perez Hilton on her unlocked
podcast in the aftermath the Chrisleys
might be stronger than ever not you but
some people might think strategically
business-wise it may be a good idea to
distance myself from my parents I was
told that yeah I was told that we need
to focus on your brand Savannah and you
know and I don't care
money means nothing you know we've been
so blessed to have such a platform to
build from it sucks and it's tough but
it's the cards that I've been dealt and
those are my parents so I'm not just
gonna give up when the going gets tough
I'm digging my heels in harder and I'm
fighting for what I know is right I
think they're optimistic and let me be
clear I think that optimism is well
placed this trial was riddled with heirs
and we expect the appeals court to see
that so what's next for Savannah you're
not doing a show on TV right not at this
moment before her parents surrendered to
prison in January the family hinted that
a reality comeback was in the works but
there is a show that will come back okay
and I think that is where boundaries
have to be set
um but also our show it was not reality
it wasn't and so a show going forward
would be reality it would be how we are
all dealing with things how we're
navigating it together as a family what
do you know about this documentary and
the message that the Chrisley family
wants to now show the world I don't have
any details about the documentary uh I
can just tell you there is there is a
story there about what they've been
through the past year or two that hasn't
been told the documentary that we're
working on right now is going to be very
talent and we hope that our fans will
Embrace that I'm going to be very
mindful of the partnership that I create
with a production company it's about
truly following what is instead of the
downfall I've never seen two people my
parents be so steadfast in their faith
in the end the truth will prevail may
get harder before it gets easier but we
have faith
[Music]
foreign